où
[Musique]
enfin
on est aujourd'hui à l'aéroport de los
angeles
heyer fini le csj partie de vegas à los
et justement je vais vous parler d'un
truc que j'ai vu l'autre jour qui est
intéressant c'est une boîte française
qu'il appelle diva corps j'en ai déjà
parlé ils font l'audio et quand une
nouveau castres qui est vachement bien
antipolis 2 je vous ramène donc à vegas
pour aller découvrir une nouvelle
solution de dit d'accord je pense que ça
va être franchement parler alors là on
les découvre en les testera
prochainement mais à mon avis
connaissant les produits qu'on ne lui à
vendredi vacances entre que coûte toutes
très rock'n'roll avec david morton
directement à vegas le temps pour moi
d'aller dormir parce que les ya quelques
heures de vol j'ai onze heures de vol
entre los angeles et paris
et là j'ai dormi une demi heure cette
nuit ne sais pas si ça se voit on a fait
la fête toute la nuit et les gas oil
suite
mais là
l'as eupen le sommet
à quel prix
et m
car tout
com
tom est donc allé voir vivent à cornes
et je vous invite à me dire ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire là on est bien
là voilà on est allé gas et tout le
monde on est avec david de diva corps
ils voient se dit d'accord et on va
parler audio alors on sait déjà
rencontrés nous inciter à berlin à l'ifa
et puis là vous avez de nouveaux
produits qui ont été présentés qui sont
présentés vous montez sur le service en
tout cas on est en train de présenter et
antipodes de la suite de notre équipe
type hot 1 qui avait cartonné déjà en
france et en europe et puis va
maintenant essayer d'exporter de
l'amiante
ouais d'accord enclave d'attaqués que le
marché américain marché américain on a
eu des contacts avec les japonais les
australiens l'accord et les émirats
après ses deux contacts engrais le
concrétiser c'est génial c'est cool
alors si tu montreras se produit alors
qu'est ce qui nous fait qu'est-ce qui
nous raconte pas l'histoire
alors ben des trous et relève donc 100%
qu'il y en a partout à toutes les sauces
c'est ce qu'on s'est dit nous on est à
la quatrième génération quand même
l'écouteur donc une certaine expertise
et on va essayer d'apporter de la magie
sur android
la magie sur android ouais tu veux que
tu expliques way comment tu me fais de
la magie sur d'autres ça me tasse en
fait on est parti du principe que ce
qu'il faut c'est que ce soit facile à
utiliser des gels et donc qu'on a tous
améliorer là quand tu l'essor du boîtier
se connecte directement dans leur
approche des oreilles et se connecte à
fait
bref ça fait court
et surtout une première mondiale on a
rajouté la fonction just as tu sais ce
que c'est vas-y dix mois en fait il
suffit
ah ok google et jacques desbois colle
sur ce com arrive à faire et repos
durant sur avec l'éco système ios
bref c'est une première sur android
habitude il fallait encore appuyer sur
le bouton dont qui sortent et device ou
interagit avec maintenant mais on
commande vocale total donc c'est
complètement magique haïti mis d'accord
ok donc commandes vocales total et en
termes de format alors en format on est
sur un mode qui est qu'il ya cette forme
qui se présente avec les avantages
d'être lippé x4 elle voit un petit
crochet ici qui permet un maintien
parfait dans l'oreille on a rajouté des
embouts à mémoire de forme pourquoi le
gros avantage c'est que ça coûte au
bruit quelle est sa coupe et également
le vent en fait en train de faire du
score souvent tu sens un petit
sifflement entre ton écoute air et ton
oreille et là en fait le fait d'avoir
des envies qui épouse parfaitement
combiné audités pour être avec ta une
meilleure captation audio un meilleur
port et en plus leur musique le passage
du vent dans les oreilles sur le reste
on est à 6 heures d'autonomie en une
charge
on a 30 euros total en usb c'est on
utilise le nouveau mode bluetooth pour
avoir une meilleure stabilité
c'est-à-dire pas le second qui passe à
gauche et à droite
bousma restent à l'arrêt à la caméra
donc on a bien le signal qui passe et à
gauche et à droite de ton oreille donc
c'est beaucoup plus fort avant il était
dupliquer maintenant
communication d'accord ça c'est vrai que
c'est marrant l'as tendu comme ça tâter
il n'y a pas de déformation dans le
temps ça bouge pas s'altère pas ça reste
vraiment comme ça non justement ces
ententes et que tu l'enlèves de tous mes
oreilles ça va reprendre sa forme
initiale c'est un peu le principe d'un
gloria mémoire de forêt les plans avant
qui mettait dedans là jusqu'à ce que tu
le fais tu dans l'oreille hilal sa forme
originale dakar et après les pouces par
cette vente ont connu des dieux auditive
d'accord t'as une partie tactile à la
grande partie tactile justement on a
aussi réalisé une prouesse n'y a pas
beaucoup de boutons sur un surcoût de
produits lorient tactile et on a réussi
à faire contrôler et des pistes et du
volume directement sur les écouteurs
pour pas avoir à sortir son téléphone
quelques fois des aphtes tu vas voir ta
beauté des multi a depuis rio seul
salaire exactement pression pour que
pression monte pour activer certaines
fonctions on peut aussi activer les
commandes vocales sur la vire en tête
quand même s'il vaut mieux ça reste de
dire ok go girl ou à une série pour
activer ses commandes vocales
on va donc aller de taiyo s android haut
niveau la commande vocale
voilà on est les seuls au monde à le
faire on est les premiers à le faire
sans avoir à toucher gens comme vous et
moi on en rit corps est là c'est pour ça
qu'on va vraiment ça super innovant à la
cépière
ben non c'est chouette voilà après au
niveau du son on a rajouté un petit
empire
c'était que c'est vrai que la qualité
sonore été amélioré tout le monde
utilise plus ou moins les manières
fighter iv le fait d'utiliser un ampli
en amont au niveau du sont forcément ça
enrichit s'amplifie tension et du foot
arrive quand on va voir un son de
meilleure qualité et un meilleur spect à
voilà c'est ça en fait je vais avoir
pour beaucoup plus propre et puis une
meilleure spatialisation de chine envers
ce petit ampli alors que ça coule par
contre ça vachement groupe cmh pas en
gros mais c'est vachement content at en
fait si tu compares au final on est en
train de mixer les fonctionnalités
derrière podz mais également d'avoir
bistrot mois il peut être il est trés
pour le sport si tu vois la taille d'un
boîtier de powerjet c'est vraiment deux
fois ce volume donc ça dépend de
fonction quand je pose la question mais
je vais mettre ça je montrerai par les
kanaks
c'est flatteur j'ai l'impression
j'ai l'impression je dois bien ça me
fait ça dans la poche alors c'est
effectivement slater il ya un côté un
peu flatteur les portes et j'en suis
d'accord avec toi mais c'est vrai que
c'est un peu un peu un peu bas laisse
comme toi c'est d'accord c'est un petit
peu balèze maintenant si tu regardes
bien le seul modèle qu'on va avoir en
référence que renan plus poussés à
rhodes
mais apple n'a en fait tu te koop de
toutes les fonctions sportives avec
probité lors que tu vas arriver aux
fonctions sportives obligés de faire des
couvertures du pays
des choses comme ça un form factor
différence va intégrer une élève pour un
maintien parfait et ça ça prend un petit
peu de place donc ça justifie la taille
du boîtier
ok ok très bien fort je l'essaie ce
produit phare de sony en bas j'ai hâte
que tu nous regardes les sionistes en
son nom avec plaisir avec en plus la
couleur du coup dit d'accord ça va comme
aujourd'hui parce que nous on s'est
rencontrés dans ce pays ça fait un an et
demi qu'on s'est vus j'ai tester vos
générations précédentes
comment ça se passe l'évolution la
société qu'est-ce qui se passe moi je te
dis on a commencé quand même la société
il ya 8 9 ans maintenant ça fait quatre
ans qu'on fait du trou wireless en 2017
gv accor a vendu autant de j b
sonic était venu trouver à l'aise dans
toute l'europe c'est une vraie prouesse
c'est alors que maintenant l'idée c'est
vraiment de dupliquer ça on est on a la
même concurrence dans le monde entier
donc si on arrive à prendre quelques
parts de marché avec nos beaux produits
français et le produit anti peu de 250
et un petit maillot termes de prix ou
des conteneurs ancré en eux assez
agressif parce qu'on reste à 144 euros
donc on est en dessous des tarifs de cas
lors du marché en offrant jeudi une
connexion la nouvelle connexion en deux
canaux assez incertain coup et après la
qualité audio qu'on a réussi à mettre
dedans tu respectes que je t'ai expliqué
justifie ok pour ça marche on reproduit
attesté avoir et je vous fais le débrief
complet sur la chaîne en tout cas merci
beaucoup de villes très cool mère et
jamais voir ça fait plusieurs fois
l'interview préoccupation ce qu'on verra
celle où les encadreurs et on voit cette
année au hellfest où les bains ça c'est
certain
des tickets
[Musique]